yeah welcome to this video playing Grand
Master mr. Floyd from hmm yeah I thought
this is Nigeria but what GM and Dion
hunted okay maybe he's working indeed in
Nigeria master coach we never know okay
the Kings Indian let's see ya Queenie
ate one of the sidelines puzzle
interesting
usually I'm night a success plate
hmm yeah this doesn't look too bad
though to blacken on it all
yeah he managed to to play him the
normal normal moves without playing
night a 6 which very often assess you
sir it's a something you need to do
yeah probably just not f6 back and
threatening to take on f5 I think
yeah maybe you can do something very
aggressive here not see 5ef bishop at 5g
phone before I don't know but otherwise
I think just Knight f6 is the normal
move after Knight f6 my idea was to play
g4
yeah at least it looks took lots of time
for it
okay so let's see is there how to how to
continue here
yeah there are some technical ideas here
I like to be four takes takes Knight
takes Knight takes pawn takes Bishop h5
Queen to g7 something like that but it's
not really helping
and 10c two assaults are not good so
what should I play here okay try to get
control over your form
or at the end get a position where he
has a pawn on e4 yeah I know Bishop g4
or maybe Bishop h5 first just helping
know the idea is to have a position
where this Bishop is blocked and I can
often pick up before later yeah yeah
it's it's difficult to to play this now
without taking on g8 what I can always
take with the rook okay let's just play
here and try to guess along
I really didn't expect him respected him
to take it looks like I'm losing a
temple Queen d2 queen d 5 but I thought
you will never take interesting
ah maybe roped you six now
yeah g6 okay if he takes twice i get i
get d 6 i surf is threatening h5 of
course
i get i get d six
oops I forgot that you can take that ok
it's not not the end of the world when I
somebody forgot it yeah i say i pick up
pick up a couple of points now check
trying to get young is ok so let's let's
check you know I can check pick up the
airport
hmm John it's just a good end game for
white I think check I can just take it
black resigns hmm Jeff we had game I
don't understand what was going on
really maybe he just played this to
ambitiously I think this should should
probably know yeah i thought i thought
okay i always have enough for the pawn
but here i could have played rugby six
now black black probably should play
some some slow move like King g7 or
something yeah you could could analyze
this in much detail but yeah he rope t6
is also good
yeah it's the the pawn extra point for
Black is just meaningless I have a king
playing a better rock and this is very
weak white is better here much better
even Rock d6 dozer was better right here
he needs to somehow switch to to try to
play for this is no no ugly here Luke g6
is also good yeah I played a plate like
this it's also good from ok check just
to grabbing everything yeah it's just
this is coming and after that i can try
to move the pawns or even yeah i'm not
sure maybe you look be eight and move
the apron ok he just had a had a
blackout IAM it gave me the rook but
they're probably it's lost in any way in
any case now very complicated game
thanks for watching